rapidement on
collectif de la part d'ubs
très rapidement vous avez ressenti son
ambition présidentielle partielle mais
honnêtement quand il est
6 2
de désigner
j'attends un peu dans les 15
les gestes c'est d'aller se faire
applaudir à tour
université d'été du medef en
1 expliquant
c'était n'importe quoi il fallait
et que par ailleurs
le jeu
ensemble
vous êtes avoir deux
ce sans travailler moi qui suis de
gauche je n'ai jamais pensé complet
travailler j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement un
jury
et j'ai vite compris qu'en fait ils
chercheraient à se faire passer pour
plus moderne
sur notre dos d'une certaine façon nous
faisons passer nous
une famille politique qui l'accueillait
des archaïques donc oui cette façon de
se comporter
il a été loyal envers le canadien de
l'attenté pour moi il ne l'a pas été dès
le début